so I know for you Joe you'd been exposed
to photos of animals and being this
environment for at least 15 to 10 years
but for you Liz where there are times
when there's got to be a little bit too
much when you saw things or maybe got
too close to certain things that were
you know very difficult to deal with and
how do you as a documentarian keep going
with a project that you said it is
really a personal journey for you in
some ways exploring some of these issues
as a as a filmmaker I've I've been on
the frontlines all over the world since
the 90s covering human rights films and
my last film is about the environmental
the world water crisis so I'm familiar
with the frontlines
but this the ghost center machine is the
first film that I've made that focuses
on suffering of the suffering of animals
the exploitation of animals so that very
new for me and it was overwhelming for
sure and I think the editing process is
always therapeutic because it's an
opportunity to sift through you know a
lot of material a lot of raw material
and to make sense of it and work through
the experiences so yeah the Toronto Pig
save vigil I worked with some wonderful
editors and I just recall this one day
when I came into the edit suite to look
at a sketch of a particular scene and
it's the vigil scene of the Toronto Pig
save activists with Joe bearing witness
to the the trucks that are going past
and I just I just broken I just started
crying and that for me was sort of like
an awareness that I had been holding a
lot in for a long time in the making of
the project and I just felt flat
with emotion and needed to take a break
and come back to it so a break is in
like a day I needed to leave the suite
and just I needed a break just to
process and then come back to the work
but anyway so that was just a moment for
me that was the gravity of it just hit
me because you know when you're in work
mode you're in work mode and you can at
least for myself I know I can detach on
a certain level but I wasn't I just you
know of course of course it's all going
to accumulate and have an impact so yeah
did the roles change in some sense were
you able to then say to Liz you know
I've been in those situations and here's
here's what I do or you just I don't
know that we ever related in that kind
of way but you know community is
important with this work that we're
doing and supporting one another and the
the the the depth of just like how bad
the situation is for animals isn't
really known and isn't really respected
if you're someone who is very empathetic
towards animals your scene is just like
a softie or weak and so it is really
important for empathetic and
compassionate people and activists to
really support each other and understand
one another
you